it's often said there's only two kinds
of people in the world those whose data
has been hacked by china and those who
don't know that their data has been
hacked by china
that statement is actually more true
than you might think
hi i'm michael beckley i'm an associate
professor of political science at tufts
university
and i'm the author of unrivaled why
america will remain the world's sole
superpower
today i'll be debunking myths about the
future of international relations
between the united states and china
the united states and china are destined
for war
i think that's not true but it's not
totally false either what i would say is
that the united states and china are
destined for rivalry they are the two
most powerful countries in the world
and have very different visions about
how the world
should work so the united states is a
democracy china is an autocracy
and certainly wants to promote that
vision of governance the united states
treats taiwan as an independent entity
in everything but name
china considers it a renegade province
the united states wants one
open global internet and china wants
every country to be able to
censor the internet as it sees fit
wired's february issue
features excerpts from the book 2034
which imagines an
all-out war between the united states
and china that starts in the south china
sea
the south china sea is an area of
dispute because that's one of the
world's
major international waterways is this
the most likely scenario
for u.s china war i think it's possible
i don't think it's the most likely
scenario
china could very well beat the united
states in a war and i think that's
especially likely if the war happens
over taiwan taiwan is only 100 miles
from the chinese mainland so china could
throw its entire military
at the conflict the chinese military
could hit targets on
taiwan without ever having to leave the
chinese mainland in the first place
the u.s military of course is coming
from thousands of miles away it would
have to operate
mainly from two bases that are on
okinawa japan those are the only two
american military bases
within 500 miles of taiwan and china
actually now has missiles
that could wipe those bases out in a
sort of pearl harbor style
surprise attack the united states would
then have to fight from guam
which is 1800 miles away from taiwan and
that's a huge problem because american
fighter aircraft
run out of gas after 500 miles these are
the kind of nightmare scenarios that
keep american defense planners up at
night and frankly for good reason
china is surveilling u.s data
that's definitely true every country
spies on every other country
but what distinguishes china's espionage
and
surveillance is just the sheer scale so
if you just look at 2014 alone
it was revealed that china had hacked
into the office of personnel management
they took the data the deepest darkest
secrets
from american government workers
including you know cia operatives during
that same year they hacked into marriott
and stole passport data and credit card
information
they also hacked into anthem and took 78
million people's
health care information so china has a
long history
of trying to gather up data on american
citizens
and so it's no surprise that now there
is this worry that it once you allow
an app like tick tock onto someone's
phone it's only one update away from
becoming spyware essentially
so for all these reasons there's a great
worry and i think a great reason to
worry
the cia is fueling anti-chinese groups
the cia has done this in the past so
during the cold war
china was conquering tibet and at the
time the cia actually
funded tibetan gorillas they of course
lost their battle
since then we just don't know what the
cia's been up to but the fact that the
united states also
backs the government on taiwan is
further
an example that chinese use to say look
the united states is clearly meddling
in our internal affairs i think that's
certainly true it just may not be
through
some of the groups that people have
surmised some people think the cia is
funding
the falun gong which is this religious
sect within
china there's no hard evidence that that
actually went through
if the cia is in fact funding the falun
gong they're running some serious
interference
because members of the falun gong have
gone on to found the epic times
which now is spreading disinformation
and conspiracy theories
within the united states that are
basically causing americans to turn on
each other
i don't know where to go with that but
it doesn't make any sense
the united states is the biggest threat
to world peace
i think that's true but i also think the
united states has the most potential to
be the biggest contributor
to peace so just as the most powerful
country in history
when the united states puts its weight
behind something the world gets remade
whether for better or for worse the
united states
has just in the last couple of decades
toppled a number of regimes
it of course has military bases on
pretty much every
continent it's the only country that can
fight major wars
far beyond its borders and the
catastrophes are
obvious you look at iraq vietnam the
list goes on
i think some of the successes though are
less obvious and one that i would
highlight is this system of u.s
alliances that got extended
after world war ii so the united states
has offered security guarantees
to dozens of nations and that has helped
create zones of peace
around the world countries that have an
alliance with the united states
have pretty much never been invaded or
had to fight major wars so what these
security guarantees have done is
essentially allow countries to not have
to build big militaries to defend their
own borders to not have to fight for
resources or market access which
was the norm for millennia prior to
1945. so while i think it's certainly
true that the united states has the
power
to wreck the world and wreck the world
it has in various ways
it also has the capability to really
make the world much more peaceful and
prosperous
the chinese government is about to
collapse
i think that's very unlikely china has
arguably the world's
strongest internal security force so
take the american law enforcement system
now add on top of that three million
additional security guards
two million internet sensors 600 million
surveillance cameras and something that
china calls the people's armed police
which is actually essentially an army of
1.2 million troops
that is directed inward at china's own
people
so the bottom line is the chinese
communist party is not going to go down
without a fight and it can fight like
hell now the only way you would actually
get
a collapse of the chinese communist
party is if there is a split
at the elite level that's what happened
prior to the tiananmen square massacre
where you had hardliners versus
reformists
and the party almost collapsed but i
think that the
china's leaders essentially learn the
lessons of tiananmen they realize that
they either
stick together or they're going to hang
separately and no one has taken this
lesson
further to heart than xi jinping who has
purged
thousands of his political rivals he's
stacked the highest decks
of the chinese government with people
loyal to him he's even written himself
into the chinese constitution so while
xi jinping certainly has created many
enemies by crushing a lot of powerful
chinese families
he his cult of personality and his iron
grip on power
will make him extremely hard to dislodge
any time in the foreseeable future
u.s china relations have worsened under
the trump administration
i think that's basically true donald
trump is the first u.s president to
really wage
full-spectrum competition with china
he presided over a huge boost in u.s
military power directed into east asia
he made the most aggressive use of
tariffs against china that we've seen
since really the second world war
it's a very aggressive upfront policy at
the same time though i don't think trump
himself was the sole
architect of this shift in u.s china
relations i think part of it was
actually reaction
to china's own rise in international
aggression
china has just become a much more active
muscular and authoritarian country
over the last decade so i actually think
u.s china relations are going to
continue on the same trend
during the biden administration the one
thing that democrats and republicans
seem to be able to agree on
is that the united states needs to get
tough with china the one major
difference is that biden is all about
multilateralism he's all about
allies and so he's trying to build an
alliance of democracies so it's more of
a difference of tactics
but the overarching strategy of what the
united states is doing with china is
largely going to remain the same
china is a superpower
not yet when analysts look at what makes
countries powerful and what has really
driven the rise and fall of great powers
over the centuries
it's a few basic components one of
course is wealth you need just lots of
money to buy
various forms of influence and invest in
technological
innovation you also need a big powerful
military in case things get tough and
you need to rectify the situation
through force
and you also need some kind of global
narrative you need some kind of story to
tell or some kind of ideology
that can help win over allies and
partners to your cause
so for all these reasons china's an
extremely important country but it still
lags pretty far behind the united states
which has
three to four times china's wealth five
to ten times its military power
projection capability
and nearly 70 allies whereas china's
only ally is north korea
the u.s dollar is the world's reserve
currency it's used in 90
of international financial transactions
china's currency is only used in about
two percent and of course america's soft
power its global appeal has taken a
pretty big beating over the last few
years
but it still ranks above china so with
gaps
this big in money and muscle and
allies and partners you can't really
consider china a superpower in the same
league as the united states
at least not yet china is the world's
largest economy that's actually true
china's rise has actually been quite
steady over the years it's gone from
a nation that was mostly dominated by
peasant farmers to one where there's a
burgeoning middle class today
if you adjust for the fact that things
like food
and clothes and haircuts are cheaper in
china than in the united states
then china does in fact have the largest
gross domestic product or gdp
having a big gdp is not the same thing
as being really wealthy or having a
strong economy gdp just measures
spending
and it would be sort of like measuring
the wealth of a family if you just
looked at their credit card statement
obviously just because you spend a lot
of money doesn't mean that you're
necessarily rich
china does have a lot of malice to feed
1.4 billion people
and no country has run up as much debt
as china over the past decade
so while china certainly does have the
largest economy that's not the
wealthiest country in the world
the world is divided between two large
economic blocks
the us and chinese economies are
intertwined in so many different ways
the big debate is over whether these two
countries are starting to
diverge whether there's this new cold
war between the two countries where
each country will develop its own
technology and those technologies won't
be compatible
i actually think there is going to be a
fair amount of what is called decoupling
between the two
economies it's going to take decades
most likely but i think there's been so
much bad blood
stored up by the recent trade conflicts
that both countries now are looking for
ways to
if not entirely disentangle at least try
to walk back some of their economic
entanglements
will china become a superpower it's
certainly possible but china will have
to overcome
two main hurdles the first is that its
economic engine
is starting to slow down so china's
economic growth rates have dropped by 50
over the last decade and i think even
worse productivity has declined by 10
so china's having to spend more and more
to produce
less and less at the same time china's
debt has ballooned eight-fold just over
the last decade no country has racked up
this much debt
this fast in peace time the second
obstacle is a geopolitical backlash
so according to china's own government
sources anti-china sentiment around the
globe hasn't been this high since the
1989 tiananmen square
massacre some of this is kovid but
frankly a lot of it is a response
to china's aggressive so-called wolf
warrior diplomacy the fear for china is
that it may be confronting
a tightening geopolitical noose at the
same time that its economy
is slowing and if both of those trends
continue china's superpower ambitions
could be crushed
[Music]
the bottom line is that for the next
decade at least u.s china competition is
going to likely continue
across the full spectrum of areas of
world politics
the good news is that these two
countries do need each other at the end
of the day they need each other to solve
big transnational problems like climate
change
to regulate the global economy so where
the hope is that cooler heads will
prevail and the two countries will in
fact cooperate
but it's certainly not guaranteed